there's a lot of talk in the market
right now about bitcoin's price it's
obviously come down about 50 but it's
held up much better than many of the
growth stocks or technology stocks but
there's one single metric that i
continue to pay attention to i consider
it the single most important metric in
all of bitcoin it's how many individuals
how many citizens how many retail people
continue to buy bitcoin the reason why
this is so important is because as the
individuals continue to stack sats it
ultimately will force organizations and
nation states into the hardest soundest
digital money the world's ever seen now
you can go ahead and you can take a look
at this metric now you can take a look
here and you can see that the number of
addresses with a balance of 0.01 bitcoin
that's about 300 of bitcoin continues to
go up and up and up we now have
officially crossed over 10 million
bitcoin wallet addresses with at least
300 of bitcoin sitting in them this is a
great statistic to continue to pay
attention to because what it highlights
is that the individuals those citizens
they are stacking sads the cheaper that
bitcoin becomes the more they keep
buying and sure they don't have as much
money as organizations or nation states
but one thing they do have is a really
really long time horizon as we have
talked about over and over again bitcoin
is the greatest savings technology in
the world no one in the world no
individual no organization can actually
devalue your savings you simply use it
as that savings technology and then you
just wait and let bitcoin do exactly
what it was designed to do